claude evin bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors vous avez déclaré sur europe
1 6 t il y a deux jours que personne
n'avait pu imaginer une telle crise une
crise inédite à contre-courant donc de
ce que l'on vient d'entendre dans le
journal où les plaintes contre
l'exécutif se multiplient selon vous le
gouvernement français n'aurait rien pu
faire de plus à la on verra lorsque
cette crise sera terminée il faudra
effectivement que l'on puisse analyser
les décisions qui ont été prises qui ont
été prises y compris d'ailleurs depuis
parfois quelques années et pas seulement
au cours de ces derniers mois dans toute
crise sanitaire dans tout temps tout
évènement imprévu dans le domaine de la
santé il ya toujours ce que nous
appelons des retours d'expérience il
faudra effectivement que l'on puisse
s'interroger revenir sur ses décisions
pour soit corrigé des décisions des
stratégies qui avait été décidée dans un
autre contexte précédemment ou pour
tirer aussi les leçons afin que face à
une éventuelle situation nouvelle
identiques ou comparable on puisse
effectivement avoir des processus de
décision qui soit différent quelles
leçons en tirer de cette crise sanitaire
plus d'anticipation plus de préparation
moi je crois que pour tirer les leçons
il faut attendre d'être sortie de la
crise 1 on voit beaucoup de
précipitation de jean becker qui
déclarait quelques jours avant
confirmant que le gouvernement faisait
trop qu'il fallait relativiser les
choses
donc il faudra reprendre l'ensemble des
cheminements qui que nous avons connu ça
me fasse effectivement une situation qui
est assez exceptionnel qui est dit mais
dites donc été difficile effectivement
de prévoir et aurait bien vu d'ailleurs
qu'il a fallu s'adapter presque au jour
le jour
donc ici on veut tirer des leçons de
cette situation il faut attendre il faut
avoir une vision globale sur l'ensemble
de la période et et c'est difficile de
porter une appréciation de manière
ponctuelle alors je serai que c'est une
tentation que dans lesquelles certains
tombe facilement ce n'est pas à mon avis
ce qui est la meilleure manière pour
pouvoir effectivement tirer les vraies
leçons de cette situation
alors on l'a vu un le personnel
hospitalier se plaint il s'est déjà
plaint depuis des mois voire des années
manque de moyens humains manque de
moyens matériels vous avez été ministre
de la santé
selon vous est-ce que ce personnel
hospitalier a à c était entendu par le
gouvernement français ces derniers temps
la question des moyens c'est-à-dire la
question des financements des moyens
financiers parce que derrière le
matériel derrière des personnels est
effectif
il ya des moyens financiers les moyens
financier dans le pib glisse il faut se
souvenir quand même il faut savoir que
nous sommes un des pays industrialisés
donc un des pays au monde qui dépense le
plus pour sa santé rapportés à la
population ou rapporté à la richesse
produite
donc il y à des questions de moyens qui
doivent être examinées mais n'ont pas
nécessairement perte de volume de moyens
mais en terme d'organisation de notre
système et c'est sans doute là dessus
qui va falloir que nous continuons de
travailler c'est-à-dire comment
effectivement avec les moyens dont on
dispose qui sont d'ailleurs depuis s'il
faut le rappeler est issu des
cotisations sociales donc les moyens ils
ne sortent pas comme ça avec une
baguette magique
donc il faut effectivement que nous
puissions continuer de travailler sur
l'organisation du système
l'organisation des établissements de
santé les d'établissement des hôpitaux
entre eux des hôpitaux par rapport à la
ville comment tout ça s'organise
comment tout ça ce cordes mieux et là
aussi ce sera d'ailleurs à une leçon à
tirer d'une situation assez
exceptionnelle comme celle que nous
vivons actuellement
donc ce que vous dites c'est qu'il y a
de l'argent mais qu'il aurait été mal
injectés dans les services de la santé
ce qui peut par exemple disputé le
manque de masques
il ya plusieurs choses dans votre dans
votre question le manque de marque
il ya une décision qui a été prise alors
qu'il faudra effectivement s'interroger
pour savoir s'il était bonne et s'il
faut pas en changer dans les années 2011
pour trait pour organiser différemment
l'approvisionnement en basque et en tout
état de cause personne même à cette
période n'a pu imaginer naturellement
que l'on puisse avoir besoin de masques
pour couvrir autant de population pour
couvrir une population qui a besoin de
changer de masque tous les quatre heures
et donc effectivement cette anticipation
n'a pas été fait mais honnêtement
personne je dis bien personne n'a
effectivement attiré l'attention sur le
fait qu' il fallait en faire davantage
il ya même des vidéos qui circulent
d'ailleurs y amène des rappels qui sont
faits sur les critiques qui ont pu être
portée je pense notamment aux critiques
qui ont été portées à l'encontre de
roselyne bachelot qui a été ministre de
la santé à l'issue d'une réelle pendant
une crise sanitaire aussi qui à l'issue
de cette crise s'est fait beaucoup
critiqué sur le fait qu'elle en avait
fait trop donc si on veut porter une
appréciation sur les décisions et je
répète qu'il faudra effectivement
revenir sur les décisions s'interroger
éventuellement changer de stratégie il
faudra qu'on intègre l'ensemble des
éléments 1 qui ont conduit à peine une
telle décision alors très rapidement
claude evin plus de la moitié près de la
moitié de la planète confiné on l'a
appris hier edouard philippe la dic le
confinement en france aura certainement
prolonger au delà du 15 avril selon vous
est-ce que le confinement aujourd'hui
est nécessaire oui il est nécessaire il
est nécessaire parce que c'est la seule
manière que nous avons d'éviter une trop
grande propagation du virus
il est nécessaire et si effectivement
progressivement
beaucoup de pays à travers le monde ont
décidé de confinement c'est qu'ils
répondent à des objectifs qui ont bien
été identifié par les professionnels
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
s'est prononcée en la matière et
personne ne peut en effet remettre en
cause le confinement c'est d'ailleurs là
la mesure la plus efficace pour éviter
la propagation du virus
certainement devant bien d'autres
mesures qui sont parfois évoqués
c'est simplement la mesure la plus
efficace
claude evin merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je répète que vous êtes en
ancien ministre de la santé merci